good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
that feels like a Monday that feels like
a celebration because the toast is back
the maternity leave has come to an end
your girls are back and we're singing
already hey Jax how are you Dan
I'm good I have slightly less energy
than you that's understandable you know
you are a year and a half older than me
so old the Elder is gonna ELD
wow wow we're gonna go there we're gonna
hit below the belt this morning oh is
that below the belt I feel like you're
really not know you hear about your age
if you're really on track for your life
like you're good I was gonna say that
that actually like if I said that to you
it would hurt that's hurtful wounding
for me not really whatsoever
um but yeah feeling really good gave
birth three weeks ago what's good counts
um but I'm really happy to be back I'm
happy to be back in my studio so we have
podcasted like this our classic remote
setup Jackson Florida Studio me at toast
HQ in New York City we haven't done this
actual technical setup in months we I
literally forgot how to do it I know
something's gonna go wrong I just have a
feeling no totally not since March
because in April like the few shows that
we did we did together in Florida so we
haven't done this setup since March
which is really crazy but I think I
think it's looking good I'm excited to
see how it all
looks post show we have so much to
update everyone so first of all it has
been three weeks since you become a
mother of two you had your son what's
his birthday yes let me guess
I think I heard you say August 13th no
oh
August 30th no that was like yesterday
what was it August 14th oh okay I was
close yeah so I have August 14th Charlie
was born August 15th Bruno's birthday
it's just kind of a jam-packed week in
my life August used to have no
significance to me but now it's like two
of my boys they're big daddy that's
that's beautiful mother how's motherhood
of two different than motherhood of one
you know what it's really great I found
personally that the change from zero to
one is so much harder than one to two
it's so much more enjoyable when you
know what you're doing like I was so
overwhelmed when I had Harry like what
do babies do all day how heck how often
are they supposed to eat I had no
concept of like breastfeeding like that
I would have to be doing it all day
every day right like I just didn't think
about it and I learned on the job and so
now having all those skills and being
able to enjoy so much of it it's really
been wonderful honestly the hardest part
of like having two I would say is just
makes you or making sure like the bigger
one like doesn't harm the smaller one
because Harry's so excited about the
baby like there's and he doesn't know
his own strength no he doesn't and
there's no jealousy as of yet like he's
just anytime he's like throwing a
tantrum and I want to cheer him up and
like want to see the baby
literal smile on his face immediately he
loves the baby but you know he doesn't
know his own strength he's still working
through his motor skills so just trying
to get them to be together but not too
close like slap each other not it's only
one way right right it's only a one-way
Street that's probably like the biggest
difficulty and also like toddlers just
have germs and they're on other kids
that are sick so like just trying to
keep everyone close but separate
well we miss you over here I can't lie
like the day you left I could tell I
didn't know you were headed to the
airport but the city just kind of became
like gray and we the city was literally
weeping for your departure we miss you
terribly I am going to see you in
literally one week for the Jewish
holidays which is nice
um but it's not the same even though I
do love remote podcasting with you I
feel like we do our best work like this
I'm so glad that you love it so much
because it allows me to live to move to
Florida to live wherever I want true and
it is a great situation being a mama at
like a new postpartum mama and having my
studio in my house is amazing this
morning I actually I got up really early
because like Charlie fed at 6 45
typically like I would go back to sleep
with him but I just like got up and did
my makeup so that I wouldn't get rich
but yeah be rushed but just the commute
up the stairs I'm not gonna lie it was
hard today my leg hurts I mean stairs
are literally my enemy I hate stairs
with every fabric of my being and I will
do literally anything to avoid them no
but also like I'm still recovering and
what's weird about my recoveries it
feels like I feel like I'm athlete like
I pulled muscles is how like when I try
and like get in the car it's like my leg
that hurts I have to like help my legs
it's you I kind of are an athlete yeah
yeah yeah that's like all those tick
tocks like what's not an Olympic sport
but feels like Olympic sport they say
being pregnant but also giving birth to
nine and a half a nine and a half pound
baby piano nine and a half pound baby
literally motherhood is an Olympic sport
mother breastfeeding yeah no and just
like being around kids is exhausting
like breastfeeding is an Olympic sport
like the woman who produces the most
like who has bags and bags in her
freezer like deserves a gold medal it's
not me I didn't win Olivia Olivia Olivia
ashrae it is a gold medalist in
breastfeeding uh 100 actually probably
because even though I don't have
children but I talk to you and just like
we're always talking about like kids and
stuff my phone serves me with like Mom
content especially on Tick Tock and I've
ended up on like super producer Tick
Tock where like women who are like super
producers when they wake up they're like
all right I have to pump after my sleep
and they will literally produce a gallon
of like literally looks like it came
from the grocery store
it's a crazy thing super producer Olivia
is a super producer I'm not one but this
time around breastfeeding is better than
it was the first time
also it just gets easier the more like
the subsequent children you have the
first time is always going to be the
hardest but like even a super producer
like Olivia didn't have a hard first
time from the get so it can happen for
people those magical people this has
just been like a really crazy chapter of
Our Lives not to make everything about
me but like I was included you were a
big part of the book and the chat yeah
of the book and the chapters close like
how do you feel I feel like it was such
a really treacherous
six months right yeah how long it was
five yeah we're in this sixth month now
18 uncertainty you know lots of anxiety
and you know knockwood God is good
Baruch Hashem we made it out on the
other end and Charlie is just
cheerleading how do you feel I feel a
glance at a glance at a glance I'm just
like whoa what a crazy five months and
as I was going through it I was aware
that I wasn't really processing anything
more than I needed to like obviously the
stuff with the pregnancy like I have to
be very present and like in making hard
decisions and stuff but like the moving
and the being in our old apartment right
and being like what we have a house like
I just wasn't processing any of it and I
felt like when I got home I would all
just feel like a dream kind of which it
does kind of but now that I'm home I'm
just like whoa and I'm also realizing
how much more furniture I need like you
like left your house half empty yeah
like it was as those things that didn't
bother me before I left like now I'm
like we need a rug here we need a Runner
here my bathroom needs this like and so
that's kind of like I just kind of want
to get into the process of like making
it our home nesting 100 yeah I really
feel like nesting so I didn't get to
nest in my pregnancy really because what
am I going to do in not my apartment
right and so now I want to do all those
things but one I can't really stand for
more than 10 minutes without having like
really bad back pain and two Charlie
won't be set down he's on his mama 24 7.
right now he's on his daddy and he's
allowing Mommy to work which he does do
he does let me work but beyond that he's
like you're not gonna Nest you're not
gonna clean out your closet you're not
gonna cook no so to confirm you are now
two for two with giving birth to boys
who support women in business yes they
do and they support working moms they
support they support working moms and
here's what you're not allowed you're
not allowed to comment on my
mispronunciations because I'm in
postpartum like yeah I have postpartum
brain I get postpartum brain worse than
pregnancy brain I was watching the
interview with Dr Fox which by the way
dropped on patreon my OB GYN who
Mr circlage like he's the guy we did a
patreon episode and it was amazing
um but I was watching the interview and
I'm just like flubbing Words left and
right okay you know what I agree I will
not comment and honestly just do it
because it's funny but like you're right
it's not cool your post-pregnancy you
are you know not sleeping it's not right
it's disgusting of me actually no I
appreciate the self-awareness but it's
just I'm not fair game right now no not
at all but so does that mean if I do it
you're gonna lay off of me or not well
the problem is that you only do it
during ads and I can't stop you from
talking business this is a place of
business when I do it and I'm reading
the stories you get to interrupt me and
make fun of me but I can't like stop the
ad like we've got to get our coin
speaking of stories we have five today
is that correct the stories just fell
down from this it took me two seconds
Mana from the heavens and sometimes when
we are on a break and we come back we do
like the five story the five big stories
but one we've been patreon for the last
month so it's all over there and two
like there's big news from the weekend
and the stories are extremely from the
last 48 hours yeah I can't wait to get
into all of their that all of that that
there is
um but like I do like really quickly
just I know my obviously maternity leave
it wasn't as important as yours but I
did kind of like do a lot so like is it
okay if I just really quickly talk about
it yeah let me formally ask you Claude
how was your break
it was amazing honestly the unemployed
life is definitely a life worth living
like it was everything like so much
sleep so much peace on day like two or
three I really figured
um it's not like a sustainable life the
unemployed life it's nice to have and a
month is a long time but I did make the
decision on like day literally day two I
was walking around I was so bored like
literally had nothing to do and I joined
the gym
and that was huge for me and I was just
checking I really wanted to be like
really active during maternity leave and
I just checked my app because it like
logs how many active days you had I had
18 active days in the month of August
which I feel like is really good
especially because I played pickleball
like five times when I didn't go to the
gym so that's like 23 active days like
that's amazing oh you had 18 active days
in the gym app just in the gym okay well
you need to get quad like I just I can't
believe this is your journey but you
need to get a wearable to track all your
activity
I know you could get an aura ring but
also whoop had reach out they wanted us
to like start wearing whoops and not to
be like that girl but like my trainer
yeah my trainer she loves she was
wearing the whoop and she was telling me
all about it she's like you gotta get
whooped I also saw this is cool and this
is not an ad for whoop but they did not
an ad they did want us to try Out Woop
and to see if we wanted to work with
them and I when I was active like three
years ago I was on the cusp of getting a
whoop and instead I got pregnant
um so similar
but I saw it on your trainer's Instagram
that the whoop when you're going to a
fancy event and you don't want to wear
the whoop with your dress like when
people wear Apple watches to a wedding
they make whoop undies where you take
off the bit of tech and you put it in
your undies that way you'll get if
you're at a wedding you'll get the
dancing points but you don't have to
walk around with that ugly thing like
when I go back on tour
think about all my steps
Claudia's tour number three brought to
you by whoop whoop it up yes okay so I
joined the gym life changing like I feel
amazing like I really do not to be like
that [__] in the first three weeks I
was like why do people enjoy this um and
I'm still not the type of like I will
I'm gonna go today and it's the bane of
my existence I woke up it was the first
thing I thought about like I'm never
gonna be one of those people I'm like I
need to sweat like no I'm just doing it
because I have to
um but I do feel myself getting like a
little stronger which is good you know
I'm not like out of breath after a
flight of stairs like when I go to lunch
at Bloomingdale's which is you know
every day daily occurrence uh when I
enter on Lexington Avenue you have to
take the stairs up and I literally like
found a way if you go through the men's
department there's an escalator
um but I've been taking the stairs like
I'm not out of breath like just little
things in my day-to-day that are changed
oh and if you like are shocked to be
hearing this and you've not been alive
for the past month I also dropped on
patreon during Jackie's maternity leave
my journey with ozempic I think there
was a lot of you know speculation about
how turdy lost her weight and a lot of
people wanting to know if I'm on ozembic
and I did a whole episode on it because
I am and now that I've You Know spoken
my truth better be sick of me prepare to
be sick of me like I can't stop talking
about it Taylor's tracker's coming on
the podcast tomorrow the whole episode
is gonna be out about it because she's
on it too it's so funny for so long
people wanting to talk wanting you to
talk about ozempic and it's like now
they're gonna wish that you would shut
up about ozone pick they're like not her
making this her whole personality uh
yeah what else it literally is your
personality I'm obsessed yeah so you
should listen to that patreon episode if
you didn't already and let's just give
like a shout out to the patreon that was
just on fire doing the most in the month
of August like we just had episodes
pouring out of us and I want to say like
of course I'm so sorry that we were gone
for a month I know that I'm not trying
to diminish anyone's trauma like I know
this is really really hard for you guys
but I feel like if you had patreon like
it really wasn't that bad we were doing
premium content audio video confessions
doctorals like it was literally a work
of art no and we were dropping like once
a week so we were just like every other
podcast right weekly and there was that
one week where there was so much news
and it was like what does the toast
think about this and we did a fast five
episode so we were really giving no I
feel weird I can't lie like knowing how
much people loved us like it feels
amazing how much they missed us it was
nice to be missed absence makes the
heart grow fonder do you think maybe
today's episode will be smartless I feel
like if there ever was a shot in hell
it's this one
yeah if although although I did I don't
know if I told you this
I found out something really interesting
about the Apple charts I don't know if
anyone cares about this but you know
we've always said the Apple charts are
like a very interesting algorithm it's
not basically oh this episode has a
million downloads and this one is two
million like it's not numeric but there
is that that does factors of course but
a part of the algorithm is subscribers
you know you can do uh kind of like how
we do on patreon you can do paid content
on Apple and if you have a paid show
like a tier of subscription on Apple you
are prioritized in the charts which
smartless is I'm just saying and we're
not we don't have subscription to Apple
subscription so
if we did we could beat smart lists
maybe but we're going to do it on our
own merits
so I hold on I just had a list of things
I wanted to update everyone on and one
of them is something that's going to
make you laugh so hard I wanted to share
a really hilarious text message I got
from a friend of mine like three days
ago okay okay
so it's my friend Marnie she works um
for like a big fashion company and she
does like a ton of um
PR like she's always sending us stuff
and she texted me that she was putting
together like a package of things for to
you and Jackie and I just received this
voicemail from my warehouse and I am
wheezing you need to listen to it okay
I'm gonna play it into the microphone do
I know Marnie
uh I don't think so okay
tell me but I wonder if you'll be able
to hear it in my microphone we'll give
it a shot
moment
call back and get this message it deals
with this note that you want to send to
this one influencer
um I I'm just I saw the way what you
wrote and I'm concerned that maybe there
was just a little bit of a typo or
something but in your original email you
you called her by the name of turdy yeah
t-u-r-d-y Lou
that struck me a little bit odd maybe I
thought it was you meant to say Trudy
Lou
um I just need to validate I have my my
wife write a card to to both Trudy Lou
and turdy Lou I'm not sure which one I
should be sending I just want you to
validate for me like the correct name uh
thanks so much we'll hold off once in
this out till you get back to me thank
you bye and so Marty's a toaster she was
tired you will hear two four be known as
Trudy Lou I love it I love it it's
giving altivia
it's giving no Trudy Liu is my name
Trudy though oh my God what a precious
angel he's so sweet she's like he's like
the sweet old man he was just like
wanting to make sure that it wasn't a
typo Trudy
that's so funny did you see that thing
that Zach sent you
um on Instagram from the Saturday Big
Ten game
it was like from Barstool posted it
reminded me so it's The Two Hosts for a
Saturday Sports football like standing
in front of the logo for yes yes for the
Big Ten Saturday and like with their new
logo and the way that the hosts were
standing it said big turd yeah no like
have me on as a guest I was crying that
is so funny
um I thought you would enjoy that that
very sweet pea Jam energy voicemail
hijama energy
so it's like kind of like what my
maternity was like you know did Marnie
tell him that it was not a typo and that
her name is turdy of course Marty
clarified and what did he say
okay
charity it is 30 it is Shelby
he said oh that poor girl yeah they
don't know that they don't know that
it's like a sign of respect
foreign
one of the other major things I did
during your maternity leave was watch
suits I think you were the one who told
me to watch it right we reported on that
yes statistic that it was like the
number one watch show on Netflix in
August right yes it was and you shared I
think on the patreon that you were
watching Suits
um season seven I'm lit up I'm obsessed
it's literally one of the best shows and
like not me being fully obsessed with
Meghan Markle now like I totally I get
it I get it yeah everyone who did watch
suits back in the day like they got it
they knew when she's like a little too
beautiful and talented to be on this
like random USA Network show like if she
didn't fit in like she just you know
where she needed to be the palace right
that's where she got right like they
were in shocked that she was dating a
prince when it was announced and what's
so funny is the show was having like a
crazy Resurgence it's like all over Tick
Tock and Mike Ross the actor who plays
in Patrick Adams that guy who's married
to Troian Bellisario
um he changed his Instagram bio to that
guy from that show that you're watching
on that app because that girl married
the prince
yeah he's like they're they're making a
moment of it these people from the show
are not like you know crazy busy working
actors like they had they had the show
oh but another fun fact you're gonna
love this the best character from the
show
is Louis Litt he's Jewish on the show
and he's Jewish in real life and real
ones will remember the girl from
princesses Long Island who was dating
his brother I think his brother's name
was like Jeff Hoffman and they were like
all from Long Island and she like
thought she was better than everyone
because like her boyfriend's brother was
like on a TV show that no one was
watching at the time but now I guess you
know it's a big deal yeah she's better
than everyone
so I went to his Instagram to like stalk
him just to see what Rick was up to and
he is in that movie that we like weirdly
have non-stop been talking about
that Tim Dylan Thanksgiving Greg
Thanksgiving he's in it I can't wait to
see it yeah it's like an Eli Roth movie
that Tim Dylan has been casting Addison
right Rick Hoffman's in it
star-studded and Rick Hoffman I then
went to go down a rabbit hole of all the
characters from suits at the Royal
Wedding because she invited every single
one of them and it was just cool to see
them all there like in their outfits but
I didn't realize because I wasn't paying
attention to the cast of suits at the
time that Rick Hoffman my favorite
character the Jewish guy
um went viral because because of his
outfit no no they like panned to him
during and he looked
miserable like you never saw a mug like
this in your life so much so that he
actually had to respond and he said very
honestly he was like I was having a
lovely time the woman next to me had the
breath
of a sewer like he was like it was so
horrible like that's what my face was
reacting to not the nuptials it was a
beautiful wedding he clarified
wow that's kind of crazy to throw her
under the bus like that I know because
it's like we know we could see her we
could see her yeah yeah yeah well I've
been sitting here for
22 minutes and I didn't mention that I'm
a new person
um in the last week or so I know because
I've been watching Love Island UK season
five and the reason why I started with
season five is because I watched Untold
Jake Paul the night I went into labor I
told this on the patreon of my birth
story and in the documentary he fights
Tommy Fury who's with Molly May and I
follow of course I had followed Molly
May on Instagram like right after she
gave birth because she's just like a
girly and she posts really great content
but then I saw Tommy on the documentary
and I was like oh I want to know more
let me go to their origin story and I'm
watching Love Island UK season five and
I came for Tommy and Molly and they are
everything and more like
obsessed Beyond a love story of a
generation and I was really like kind of
with blinders on like I'm here to like
watch the Nuggets of them wear Tommy and
Molly in the background like what her
tummy and Molly doing here and the way I
have just fallen for Maura Higgins and
Mora and Curtis like Claudia you
actually have to watch and I know
everyone says you have to watch Love
Island UK and we always ignored them
yeah I have not had this much of like a
vocal reaction like every time they talk
on screen or like kiss or have are cute
like I'm literally attack like oh my God
I'm dying like I literally am laughing
cackling they're both so funny smiling
I'm so invested and it's been a
wonderful postpartum companion show like
Zach and I watch it every night after
Harry goes down but then like Charlie
doesn't actually fall asleep for the
night until really late so we probably
get like five episodes in every day and
it's been so good we have like four left
I'll miss it but I also am ready to see
how it ends what happens so then I can
go stalk everyone pretty sure Curtis and
Maura aren't together right now because
I followed her on Instagram already and
she looks like a single girl and maybe
she's dating like a private business man
Bo who doesn't want to be on her
Instagram but if she was dating Curtis
Pritchard from the show like they'd be
of course they would be blowing it up
they're definitely not together plus
this was literally 2019 like it's crazy
that Tommy and Molly are still together
and that they have a baby and that
they're engaged it's so sweet it's so
sweet Molly's in New York this week
should we get her on the toes well now
that I'm gone no but maybe it's good
that I'm gone because maybe she wouldn't
have come on the toast and then it would
have hurt now I could just say it's
because like
yeah like Molly Molly didn't reject us
because we never reached out right right
you can't get hurt if you never get up
you know right but I do think she would
have loved the toast and
I would have loved to have her but
anyways it's been wonderful quality like
you really should watch like I don't you
don't understand how I literally cannot
watch anything till soon it's over Ben
is a suits like torturer actually he's
like making me hate the show because
I've been really into the US Open I want
to watch it like every night Ben sits
every like we watch you it's Google
shoots I'm like listen I'm in my tennis
girl era I'm actually I think I'm gonna
go to the US Open this week I'm just
like trying to find tickets they're like
crazy expensive
um and every time I put on tennis he's
like but what about suits it's like so
annoying I can't watch anything else
when I'm done with suits I'm already on
season seven I'm almost at season eight
I will watch Love Island I promise what
platform Hulu
Hulu got it and the only person who's
loving the experience more than me is
Zach who which is so nice never heard of
Love Island like I'm explaining like
Casa more and I don't I'm not even a
love Island expert but he's like how do
you know all of this I'm like I don't
know it's my job I did watch like the US
first three seasons so I know like how
Casa Moore works and like you know all
the recoupling and whatnot but it has
just been honestly like it's been such a
positive
in your post party in my postpartum
Journey like I feel like the show that
you watch when you're like I haven't
been watching while I'm breastfeeding in
the night because Zach is sleeping and
sleeping I can't watch without him he
won't let me and if he watched without
me no no just got divorced um but I feel
like the show that you watch in those
days right after you give birth is
really a big part of your mental health
and like uh you're here you're thinking
about it all the time and even when
you're sleeping you're like barely
sleeping or just like thinking about
whatever you're watching or reading and
it has been such a great show for this
experience I love that and you know I've
been like dogging TV for the last few
months yeah I don't want to say that but
like you were like kind of negative like
a few months ago no but but that's just
because the content's negative and the
content is bad and when the content is
good I'll be the first one to say it and
Rave about it but maybe your opinions on
these shows were just a reflection of
your headspace at the time I'll give it
a shot what did I hate I'll go watch it
everything what did I hate
I don't remember I need a specific
you watched uh selling Sunset I love
that like I hate loved it yeah yeah yeah
I don't remember oh shrinking shrinking
which was good like stop
I should but the thing is I feel like it
would take more to impress me now
because I'm like so drained I'm so like
this is stupid you know what I mean like
yeah I feel like it
that just is a testament to how love
island is amazing this particular season
perhaps no it is it would take more to
impress me now
I am gonna watch it like for sure
you're gonna be obsessed Curtis and
Morris
and
speaking of TV I cancel my cable like
added to the list of things Jackie told
me to do a million years ago Jackie
can't cut her chords I thought it was
the weirdest thing I'm like girl
everyone has cable and she got YouTube
TV cut two literally two days ago
because I was watching the US Open and
spectrum is in like some legal battle
with ESPN that I couldn't get ESPN so I
was like you know what [__] it I called
them and I canceled and now I have
YouTube TV and you know what my life is
no different it's not better it's not
worse it's no different which is good
and it's savings oh I'm now I'm saving
like a couple hundred dollars a month I
was paying so much for cable I already
added to the list don't worry yeah so it
was Downton reading cable do you want
seriously do you want the official list
we haven't updated it you have to add
cable and I think you have to add like
exercising oh totally what is this is so
sad I know hold on okay Downton reading
reading on a Kindle
the phrase how you learn you hated it
when I used to say it so true the show
succession yeah pickleball Yellowstone
the Yellowstone pickle ball 100 I'm
obsessed cord cutting and what did you
just say exercise yeah
and you know what like we'll be on the
list
like in due time I mean I could tell you
everything but sure guess what I'm
guessing love Island no no because I
agree with you I'm not stubborn again
okay okay so this is things I was
stubborn against but obviously it was
wrong about
I don't know motherhood oh I that's what
I was thinking but I was like that's you
know
it's a little presumptuous for you to
say it yeah yeah yeah no oh speaking of
you know today's a new beginning
beginning of a new dawn at the toast so
it's only appropriate that I woke up
with my period
you know what's so funny is that for the
girl me who like hates talking about
periods on the podcast
we did literally a whole episode with an
OBC
period menstrual hormones like birth
control it was all
but like I'm okay with talking about
periods if we had an episode dedicated
to periods with an expert that's totally
fine you know you know what my issue
with talking about periods is yeah like
when people like just like use it as a
blanket excuse for everything no I'm not
using it as an excuse I'm just you just
want to update everyone that it truly is
like the dawn of a new age here yeah a
new egg dropped right like if it's how
symbolic that today of all day seriously
it's like a rebirth yeah it's kind of
beautiful
but when you put it like that I think we
did it was important I think duty to
know thank you no honestly this is a
battle I have lost
I'm not gonna die on this hill that we
can't talk about period
even though that wasn't my initial
thesis even though that wasn't my
initial thesis which I actually when you
said it I agreed with it's like people
on the internet like don't need to
announce that they're on their periods
like it's just unnecessary like I agreed
with it but ever since you said that I
don't think a month has passed where I
haven't acknowledged my period publicly
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah that happens had you never said it
I never would have brought it up it
happens to me too sometimes where I'm
like again something but then I find
myself doing it oops see this 100 it's
this leg
this leg my left leg like won't move
like when I get into the car I gotta I
gotta like hoist my leg wow but it
really feels like I pulled a muscle
that's what if you did like you
literally were Contracting your whole
body to push out a 10 pound baby like
it's not that crazy that your legs a
little sore
you know yeah it's just not what you
would it's not the pain that you would
expect when you think of birthing pains
100 that's been the lingering pain as
well as back pain which is just lovely
but I do have like uh ultra strength
ibuprofen
and your Poise pads and my poise pads
which I love if you guys aren't patrons
which unfortunately a lot of you aren't
it's literally disgusting no I'm kidding
I'm kidding um you would have heard how
the poison what no no nothing nothing
you would have heard how I really did
use my poise pad when my water broke and
I only needed to use one it absorbed
right up
[Music]
it absorbs right up also not an ad but
just letting you know like we are so
authentic like all of our sponsors are
coming through at different stages of
our lives and different stages of this
episode you want to know my outfit head
to toe Lululemon
actually head to ankle shoes are Prada
of course they are oh speaking of shoes
if you're watching as a video today I
don't want to trigger warning trigger
warning look what shoes I'm wearing I
just got those two in that color
original toasters will remember the kind
of raggedy white pair of loafers that
Jackie wore day in and day out at our
old studio for approximately two years
and people started to say stuff like
they really started to comfort the shoes
and you know what I was one of those
people edit the list and Nicholas Kirk
went Flats because I'm like Jackie first
of all like those shoes like throw them
away like they're they were my everyone
called them my granny shoes and like
they were a little old lady but it was
more so like the condition that they
were in you know like you wore them
every day they were like white they had
gotten a little sad
um but cut two you know they were on
sale Jackie sent me a link and I
actually bought them literally I've
never had a pair of shoes that makes my
legs look longer and skinnier and I
stand by that so you know what once
again we were wrong and Jackie was right
yeah also it was when you came down to
Florida and raided my closet that you TR
you wore a pair of them and you loved
how you looked you're gonna like the way
you look you guaranteed it I did and so
much so that she bought the shoe and I
bought that color too the beige ones
that you're wearing so now I have the
gorgeous fall Footwear gorgeous fall
Footwear but it's also because like
granny is in style right now granny is
in you are just a little ahead of your
time yeah which is fine Shakespeare you
weren't even appreciate Shakespeare
wasn't even appreciated in your own time
and you're certainly not oh my God
certainly not certainly certainly you
guys don't even know you guys don't even
know
no I do feel very appreciative got a lot
of Outreach and love
um just over the last few weeks you guys
are the best and I am so happy to be
back
doing the show moving forward let's do
like a little housekeeping obviously
everybody saw the schedule for this week
it's posted on our Instagram we've got
great co-hosts you will be checking in
with us minimum once a week correct
minimum once a week for this uh next
month
so like see how it goes you know if you
want to come back twice a week like we
would absolutely love to have you but no
pressure of course yeah so far so good
um not to like jinx anything but I think
for September expect me once a week okay
October like more than that I'm also
should be coming to New York in October
so that would be like a five day by the
way book launch is coming soon book
launch I wanted to mention the books I
felt like I haven't mentioned in a while
I was a little like quiet on the home
front but my children's book is coming
out October 10th almost a month away
it's called the camper and the counselor
and it is so amazing and wonderful and I
actually haven't given this update
um because people are gonna think I'm
lying but I'm not it is literally
Harry's favorite book we read it every
night before bed every hasn't memorized
he has like he finishes every single
stanza whenever I finish more we do it
again and again and again miss Rachel
yeah the Miss Rachel Moore and I keep
reading until like I have to be like
okay no hurry it's time for bed
um he he calls it counselor like when he
wants to read the book He's a counselor
I'm like counts like and I'm really not
lying it is his favorite book of all of
the books and when you put him down when
you put him down for bed does he say
mommy the windy Camp roads give me
goosebumps and chills he does sometimes
no that part's a lie see I'm not gonna
lie he doesn't say July
um but he loves it so much and I really
didn't like push it on him like you
better like mommy's book it was just
like always around the apartment no but
he better like mommy's right and I read
it to him like a few times like just to
test out the product and he absolutely
loves it like it's
it's an amazing book and it's it's Mom
tested and Harry approved and that's
because like children's books that rhyme
are far superior even though the
industry says otherwise yeah and it's
full of colors there are so many like
little things that he's like bird brush
because there's like a hairbrush uh they
are drinking tea he loves tea so he said
tea
um yeah he loves T and it really is his
favorite book and it's just really great
for kids like it's you should get it
that's what I'm saying so head over
check Amazon Link in my bio Google where
everybody who knows you know where to
you know where to find me you know and
you can still get a signed copy via Talk
Shop live so fabulous if you want to do
that go and do that before that's no
longer an option let me ask you a
question
um
do you think it's time like so I've been
thinking about that like um
one hand it is time
and if the stories weren't so
interesting amazing I would continue to
wax poetic about how much Harry loves
his mommy's work but
given that people want to hear about our
takes on these stories it's time but
otherwise it wouldn't have been time
because like we could have recapped the
last month for an hour and a half I know
but I feel like we have like a job to do
here today we do
we do and I think I didn't like get
dressed and haka for nothing right right
right so without further adieu it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
a brand new sponsor that I'm very
excited about because this was a product
and a brand in my daily skincare routine
CeraVe so CeraVe as a lot of us know is
a number one dermatologist recommended
acne brand and they have a line of
products developed specifically for acne
prone skin to promote clear complexion
all formulated with three essential
ceramides so you can disrupt the acne
cycle without disrupting the Skin
Barrier so if you are struggling with
acne CeraVe is just a skin care brand
that you can really really trust and I
think with acne some people get um
really insecure and they think they have
to go like really really high end or you
know more complicated but CeraVe is just
like a really good reliable simple brand
that uses really really good ingredients
and effective acne cleanser is the first
step in your anti-acne routine two of
the most commonly recommended
ingredients for treating acne is benzoyl
peroxide and salicylic acid so salicylic
acid Works to exfoliate and unclog pores
it removes dirt and acne causing debris
the CeraVe acne control cleanser
contains two percent salicylic acid to
reduce blackheads and prevent new brake
workouts and improves the appearance of
pores and contains oil absorbing
technology making it a great option for
maintaining a clear complexion and
preventing new breakouts cerave's acne
foaming cream cleanser is a four percent
benzoyl peroxide treatment to clear acne
pimples help prevent new breakouts and
allow skin to heal the formula contains
hyaluronic acid niacinamide and three
essential ceramides that leave skin
feeling comfortable and they just
launched a new 10 maximum strength
benzoyl peroxide wash which is the
CeraVe acne foaming cream wash it is the
highest concentration without a
prescription available it clears face
and body without disrupting the Skin
Barrier so whether you have acne on your
skin a lot I know a lot of people get it
on their chest back shoulders you can
use that wash on your body their am
facial moisturizing lotion and PM facial
moisturizing lotion are recommended by
dermatologists these moisturizers
contain three essential ceramides to
help restore the Skin's natural barrier
visit CVS in store or online at cvs.com
to receive buy one get one 40 off on the
entire CeraVe Acme line the promotion
runs between September 3rd and September
9th and September 17th through September
21 third so CVS in store or online at
cbs.com to receive that buy one get one
forty percent off on the entire CeraVe
acne line today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmer's dog so if
you have a streis brethren in your life
you know how important it is to keep
them healthy it contributes to a long
life and we believe that all dogs should
be eating real fresh food
um it is the farmer's dog is so easy
it's delivered to your door monthly you
freeze it you squeeze it they give you
this little quiz before uh when you sign
up to learn all about your stress brow
based on their breed their activity you
know
poops things like that and when you
switch over to the farmer's dog you will
have a noticeable difference in so many
things and uh about your dog like for
Theo I noticed his breath was so much
better his breath was a really big
problem for me I thought it was just
like dog breath but Loki it was like not
normal and now that he's eating fresh
healthy dog food his breath is so much
better shinier coat his poops are better
scheduled they're you know smaller more
just like what duties should be you know
there's so many health benefits
um the farmer's dog makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog food it's developed by
by vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from real healthy ingredients
to Human
safe to human food safety conditions and
standards so it's the best option for
dogs at all life stages because it's not
kibble it's not canned goo it's just
real healthy food traditional dry and
wet dog food options are highly
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they are extremely difficult to
portion accurately and the farmer's dog
isn't just fresh higher quality food
they also send the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs so get 50 off
your first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast
that's uh free shipping included when
you go to thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50 off
your first box plus free shipping
thanks Claude you're welcome okay our
first story I personally think it's the
biggest story of the last few days and
the most surprising Joe Jonas and Sophie
Turner are headed for divorce TMZ
reported on Sunday sources with direct
knowledge told TMZ that Joe had his
people contact and consult with at least
two LA area divorce lawyers and he's on
the cusp of filing for divorce to end
his marriage to Sophie TMZ sources say
the couple has had serious problems for
at least six months they're told over
the last three months Joe has been
caring for their two young children
pretty much all of the time even as his
band was touring they're told Joe
currently has the kids as the the group
is playing shows around the U.S on the
surface though it seemed there are no
signs of trouble
um they have attended events together
however in recent rains weeks Joe was
seen not wearing his ring
but last night uh there was a Jonas
Brothers concert or two nights ago and
Sophie was in attendance Joe was wearing
his ring he also posted to Instagram
yesterday a picture of him where his
ring is like front and center yeah but
like then TMZ clearly you know they're
trying to say something TMZ updated
their story with a shot of him from a
few weeks ago not wearing a ring to go
get coffee which like means nothing
means nothing but TMZ is maintaining
that they are headed for divorce
so let's just talk about the initial
shock of this news like when I saw this
I was genuinely shook this is a couple
like to me that is just set and I don't
think about them they don't like you
know have drama or anything I just don't
even think about their their viability
as a couple because to me they're just
like married you know like they're
they're not they're not in the tabloids
they're not salacious at all and I feel
like they're really well matched for
each other personality wise Fame wise I
feel like they're really happy they just
had their second kid so this was
extremely shocking news and part of me
just I couldn't believe it and then you
know her being at the show and him
wearing his ring and posting on
Instagram kind of
pointedly
made me think it's not true like I don't
know what to believe now
I usually am the first to stay in denial
and when I first saw this music I was
genuinely shocked but then I kind of
came around to the idea you know they're
both like very young when you are like I
I could imagine
I came around to it I was like oh okay I
guess they're not gonna work out that's
really sad now they're not denying the
rumors but they are kind of trying to
throw people off the scent so I feel
like they just want to buy more time for
themselves but I I don't feel like it's
them saying nowhere together because
they would have put out a statement or
something right and I guess like if they
are separated her being at the show is
like not that crazy if the girls or do
they have two daughters yeah if their
kids are on tour with him right you know
she wants to spend time with the kids
and they want to go to the show like
it's not the craziest thing especially
if it's like decently amicable right and
so I feel like them
doing the stuff that they did in the
last few days of rings and shows and
whatnot is just them trying to like
maintain a bit of privacy by throwing
people off the scent
um not necessarily rebuking the fact
that they're having marital troubles the
TMZ article was extremely shady towards
Sophie
um basically saying you know she hasn't
been with the kids at all even though
Joe's on tour the kids are with Joe she
hasn't worked much since Game of Thrones
like it was very shady and it made me
think like where the information comes
from like if that's coming from Joe's
camp like
that's really like it could be a sign of
trouble yeah but I don't think it's
coming from Joe's camp like with Joe's
knowledge like I don't think that like
maybe there's some like Rogue team
member who knows stuff who like went to
TMZ but I don't think Joe would be
actively trying to like put this
narrative out there especially if he's
also like working with Sophie to make
sure things look like they're okay right
right like they're a team still right
like maybe like one of the lawyers that
he met with well that's like actually
illegal I don't know but you know maybe
somebody heard a whisper and they're
like oh Joe met with two lawyers and
Sophie's not with the kids and blah blah
blah yeah
this is this is just really shocking to
me honestly like if you would have asked
me which of like the Joe Bros would get
divorced honestly I never would have
said Kevin and Danielle I never would
have said Joe and
Sophie and honestly like these days I
don't think I would have said Nick and
Priyanka like I think when they first
most people would have said Nick and
Bianca because people love to doubt them
and they'd love to prove people wrong no
it's so true but they're also like the
most in my opinion like private
about their relationship Joe and Sophie
are actually pretty private too like now
they are I think in the beginning they
weren't nobody even knew Sophie was
pregnant the second time yeah yeah until
she like posted I think in a carousel
not even the first picture yeah a
picture of her like and giving birth
yeah yeah yeah
I mean I don't know who I would have
said got divorced first but to me I just
thought that these two were really solid
so this is just shocking news it is I do
want to hold out hope that TMZ doesn't
know what they're talking about but they
not only like put out that first article
they're doubling down they're not like
being here always right TMZ is always
right I think this is a situation like
where there's smoke there's fire for
sure but I don't
I think it's still in flux you know
maybe they're trying to work things out
maybe they are separating maybe one of
them is having a hard time and needs
some personal time yeah you know
I don't know man this is really just
shot like actual shocking news it takes
a lot to shock me it takes a lot to
shock me too it's shocking and it's sad
it is sad especially because they just
had a baby and it's not to make it about
us but we've always cited them as an
example of a couple that could be
extremely busy and still make it work so
you're scheduling conflict excuse for
breaking up as a celebrity couple like
has no merit
because Sophie we've also used them as
an example of like like how amazing it
was that Joe Jonas was able to actually
you know date on his level after Gigi
Hadid but it's still an example of that
yes it is it is it is it is it's just
sad that it wasn't a happy ending but I
guess it's still an example of busy
schedules being able to thrive in
relationships because when the Jonas
brothers were making their comeback it
was the final season of Game of Thrones
like you couldn't find it's actually so
true or more successful people actually
I feel like right now their schedules
are less busy so it has nothing to do
with schedules
yeah now people are obviously like
pulling footage from the last couple of
weeks of shows Joe had cried during one
song and like it kind of was out of
character for him to cry he's like not
the emotional one he's kind of like
Goofy yeah but like I Cry Sometimes
you do like even heroes cry
you know there's a million reasons to
cry yeah sometimes the song just like
really comes over you and like it's like
not even your favorite song or not even
the best song but you just get like kind
of like taken by the song no it's so
true and you're like on the huge stage
with your Brothers performing these
songs yeah how can you not cry
so true what song was it
a little bird or something I don't even
know it I wonder what like what it's
about I I imagine it goes a little
something like this
little bird oh you're so little and
you're a bird so fly away okay it's
about like a daughter
and okay well that'll make you cry it
literally listen to the lyrics I'll try
and read them without crying okay okay
you came in the world my baby girl
beautiful angel oh I could cry got your
mother's kind eyes
trying to stop time no I could never ask
for more darling there's a train coming
in your life that you gotta catch but
that's not right now
oh my God this song is literally
designed to make you cry okay I'm sorry
I made fun of it no no not even that
he's not crying about Sophie no yeah
it's fatherhood it's emotional kids
growing up time is fleeting yeah small
hands wrapped around my finger wrapped
around my finger
and we dance try to let it linger try to
let it linger because I know if I'm
doing my job correct nights like these
will happen less so oh my God
I have chills I can't so please just
keep me in your heart when you fly into
somebody else's arms little bird
oh that's really sweet not me being like
such a [__] making fun of it no I
didn't I I don't know I didn't know you
were making fun of it
little bird fly and now I need to listen
to the song and try not to cry like
number one favorite song
title of today's episode and play my
music all night long to me that's the
best Jonas Brothers song oh really yeah
play my music literally from Camp Rock
in my humble opinion is the best Jonas
Brothers song my humble opinion states
that the best Jonas Brothers song is Fly
With Me
that's also a really good one you know
what Loki they have like so many bangers
used to pray for a moment just like this
there's a fire and I can't resist baby
we're gonna wanna remember this yeah
we're gonna wanna remember so good
so good like they kind of are like
amazing yeah so we'll keep you posted on
Joe and Sophie oves
jophey it's really It's upsetting it is
upsetting and I hope that whatever comes
that they're able to
coexist work through for the kids yeah
are you ready for our next story I am
another shocking split
summer house Stars Carl oh my God and
Lindsey Hubbard called off their
engagement this weekend uh Entertainment
Tonight had the exclusive that they
caught off their engagement and it was
all caught on camera sources told E.T
that Carl and Lindsay have called off
their engagement the two were set to get
married in November but Carl told
Lindsay he couldn't move forward with
the wedding the breakup was filmed and
will most likely play out on the next
season of summer house just two weeks
ago she had her bridal shower yeah in
the city uh several of her co-stars were
in attendance and now this
no this is shocking they were literally
getting married in November like this is
a close call
um I'm shocked and I'm a little annoyed
because I really took their side last
season and now I look stupid that's
exactly how I feel I I look forward to
finding out what happened because I feel
like maybe
it could still vindicate us you know
like yeah I can't explain it but I still
even though they didn't work out as a
couple like I still stand firm that
Danielle's reaction to their engagement
was insane the craziest thing I've ever
witnessed even even now looking at
through the prism of two people who
aren't meant to be yeah aren't getting
married like that's just not how you
react when your best friend gets engaged
no I stand by everything like I believed
in their love and I'm not gonna
apologize for believing in love ever no
and I also just like believed in the way
that they were treating their
relationship as an adult relationship
and taking themselves very seriously
like completely agree I stand by what I
said I honestly don't even know the two
of them well enough I don't think I ever
said these two are meant to be and
everything like I just I liked it I like
that they were like yeah yeah and like
acting like adults unless they say
something like we were too serious too
fast yeah unless they say they move too
fast even though I don't think the
timeline was that crazy no me neither
not in
not compared to like lay people you know
yeah no and keep in mind these are two
people who have known each other for
like over 10 years right I don't think
it's so crazy either but this news was
shocking right and apparently it's a
shock to Lindsay as well it's not like
they came to this decision I think he
blindsided her he did it on camera so we
shall see in a few months whatever this
moment was crazy because one thing I
actually respected about the
relationship is that they kept things to
themselves like especially off camera
like they didn't air Dirty Laundry like
they
you know presented a united front which
I think is really good for a
relationship so to just be blindsided on
camera that's a kind of like out of
character of Carl in terms of their
relationship I feel like he was always
like protecting Lindsay and that's one
thing I actually really respected about
their relationship
um so this is crazy but it does lend an
opportunity for like this Redemption of
Lindsay
like all the girls like she's gonna
become like a victim energy now
um and I think the audience will will
feel for her I do think this could kind
of be like a Redemptive moment I don't
think she needs to be redeemed
now I don't either but we were in the
minority I know but that just frustrates
me and also
I don't know
we'll have to see what happened because
if I were Lindsay and all these people
didn't support my relationship like I'm
also not running over to you in my time
of need yeah yeah but there's limited
people you know she's in despair she's
stuck in this house with people like she
needs a shoulder to cry on yeah well
she's friends with that girl Sammy
Samantha
and I also do think her and Danielle are
on the mend yeah I saw Danielle said
something about the breakup but I didn't
click that she did somebody had cited uh
the scene in Sex and the City movie one
where big uh leaves her at the altar and
the Charlotte hugs Carrie while they're
like in the limo fighting and she's like
no no and Danielle commented like I am
Sharla
yeah it was cringe but I assume that
means they're on good page I don't know
okay well I'm sad about it honestly I
this was another thing that genuinely
shocked me and also made me a little
annoyed
yeah me too like oh my God the one time
I like stand for something of course
they break up yeah not cool
not a cool ask
are you ready for our next story
I don't know am I no you don't look
ready if we're being honest I'm not
because uh the next story excuse me is
brought to you by kitch game changing
that's what kitch's biggest fans say
about its time saving Beauty Essentials
for Hair Skin and Body are you ready to
change a beauty game they say that hair
care is the new skincare but there's one
brand that's really taking it to the
next level with a cult-like following
kitch has created game-changing
essential Beauty Essentials that the
beauty enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time saving towels
kitchen knows hair care doesn't stop in
the shower so uh kitch is a brand I
adore I have so many of their Clips like
so many of their different
um hair products especially like I'm in
my blowout era I don't know if anybody
noticed like I don't really curl my hair
anymore I've been like trying to
preserve a weekly blowout and that
requires some products when you sleep
like an animal the way that I do so
whatever your budget whatever your skin
or hair type kitchen believes that you
deserve little indulgences at affordable
prices they started selling hair ties in
2010 door to door and now they are
carried in over 20 000 retail locations
maybe you've seen their satin
pillowcases their caps and their eye
masks all all of which I have been using
I like a satin dream when I go to sleep
now because it really helps me wake up
like without a Rat's Nest that I don't
have to like fully blow out again
um
they also have heatless satin curling
rollers if you want to get rid of heat
damage their latest viral craze is the
rice water shampoo bars which can
improve your overall hair growth and
density reviewers say that they'll never
use bottle shampoo again and their hair
feels like a thousand percent better
between washes plus right now for a
limited time you can live the Barbie
dream life with the Barbie by kitch
collection so right now kitchen's
offering you 30 off your entire order at
mykitch.com toast that's right 30 off
anything and everything at
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast that's
mykitch.com toast for 30 off your order
today's episode is also brought to you
by Court life is always changing and
your furniture should be able to change
with it with court furniture rental you
can get the furniture and services that
you need to help make everyday life
transition as seamless as possible so
whether you're making a short-term long
distance move relocating starting a new
chapter or you simply don't want to be
tied down by owning Furniture court has
a solution for you simply pick the
furniture you want then their expert
team delivers and sets it up the
furniture will be there when you need it
and gone when you don't get furniture
picture on your own terms with court
furniture rental and visit court.com
slash podcast to learn more and find the
furniture package that fits your life
that's cort.com podcast so you can have
furniture on demand which I think a lot
of us aren't used to and being bogged
down with so much Furniture especially
if you live like a more relaxed you know
untethered lifestyle and you love to
travel having so much Furniture can be
like kind of a pain and then you have to
find storage or if you just like to keep
up with like Furniture Trends they
change so quickly so having Court
furniture rental at your disposal is
kind of like a gorgeous thing make room
for something new without leaving a mess
behind to clean up Court will pick up
what you've rented Without You lifting a
finger and by renting you're supporting
a more sustainable way of living which
of course is fabulous so again that link
is court.com podcast
c-o-r-t.com slash podcast to learn more
and find the furniture package that fits
your needs this is a fabulous premise I
feel like it's kind of revolutionary
fabulous premise
kind of revolutionary kind of
revolutionary honestly I feel like
court.com podcast yeah it's a great
thing great resource okay our next story
Travis Barker's family emergency has
been revealed pregnant Kourtney
Kardashian was briefly hospitalized so
Travis Barker had to abruptly fly home
from blink 182's tour after his pregnant
wife Kourtney Kardashian was
hospitalized according to a new report
the reality star had a brief stay in the
hospital is now back home with her kids
she's feeling better uh People magazine
insider added she's happy to have Travis
back home too so Travis is on tour the
band put up an announcement that Travis
had to go home for a family emergency we
all know Courtney is pregnant and she
had a brief stay in an LA area hospital
and she checked out of the hospital on
Saturday weirdly there's paparazzi
photos of her leaving the hospital
so rude so rude
I feel like for him to have canceled
like so many big shows it had to have
been like a serious thing and to be in
the hospital is obviously so scary but
like pregnant is even scarier so
honestly I'm not gonna be a snoop I
would love to know what's going on but
like I'm genuinely wishing her the best
like for real genuinely wishing her the
best I'm glad that she was able to leave
I hope everything's okay I understand
big or small when you're pregnant wife
is in the hospital like you leave your
show and I feel like maybe not every
single artist would do that they would
wait to see like what's going to be how
it lands but like the way that Courtney
and Travis are you know that they want
to be by each other's side through
everything like
it makes sense that he dipped and is
going to be with her yeah I feel like
one of my biggest takeaways from the
most recent season of the Kardashians
it's like Travis is like everything he's
such a good husband he's such a good
daddy such a good step dad he's such a
good I think he's also like a
I don't even know what the relationship
Guardian Shanna Moakler the oldest
daughter Atiana is not Travis's
biological kid but you would never know
that like he treats him he treats her
you know like loves her lives with her
it's like I the more I learn about
Travis like the more I'm obsessed yeah
he's really just a family man
because he looks so hardcore right but
he's like deeply emotional and you know
he's been through a lot and he didn't
fly for all those years like he's kind
of this like onion
onion
right well now this onion is with his
wife
and the kids because I saw Penelope went
with uh anti-coco and Auntie Kim and
lovey to the Beyonce concert last night
so obviously like the whole family's
pitching and you know making sure the
kids sure Courtney's recovering I'm sure
all the kids are at Grandma's it's nice
it's nice but I also could have seen
Penelope going with North and Kim to the
concert even without this like that's
very much like what they do north and he
are best friends so yeah I'm I'm glad
everyone's having a good time which
actually leads to our next story our
next Kardashian story which is Kylie
Jenner and Timothy chalamet cozying up
at Beyonce's Renaissance tour in their
first public outing together so
Beyonce's tour made its way to LA
a lot of celebs in attendance a lot of
headlines but the biggest one is Kylie
and Timothy together kissing loving each
other having a great time
so this is in my opinion like the first
real photo we have of them the other one
was like them smoking cigarettes outside
in someone's backyard and they weren't
even touching like to me those those
could have been to to any any two people
yes but it did give Credence to what to
me sounded like an unfathomable rumor
that the two of them were dating like I
would have never guessed it so just the
fact that it was her and Kendall and
Timothy and Kimber like it meant
something yeah no it was it was further
confirmation but to me like this is so
next level like the kissing photos
holding each other and I think before I
saw these photos like I would have said
this is a weird couple I'm like I'm not
into it I genuinely do not understand
the Timothy chalamet hype like how he
gets the most beautiful women in the
world is like one of the great Mysteries
to me and I'll just never understand it
having seen these photos I don't still
fully understand it but like I'm
definitely on board for this
relationship they looked really happy
they're the same height it was cute yeah
I think what makes the relationship cute
after seeing these photos is seeing the
height that I would have expected that
he would be like really small yeah I
mean I I knew that he's small that is
part of like my hypothesis as to why I
don't understand the height no but like
together Kylie's tallish
for a girl like I weigh more than
Timothy Charlamagne yeah no they look
they look really cute together and they
do she looked really beautiful and
really happy yeah really beautiful and
really happy you know what these are
photos like we've never gotten of Kylie
she wasn't doing this with Tyga she
wasn't doing this with Travis Scott like
they were so much more private and this
is just like so unserious
from Kylie who's like always does
everything like you know very seriously
I I enjoy this fresh energy I think
she's just living life you know yeah
he's so young that's the thing like I I
was kind of I see her as this like
serious old woman because she had kids
so young and she has this like billion
dollar business and she's just
accomplished so much she's accomplished
just as much as like her mom you know
yeah but she's literally 24.
right 26 maybe whatever she's so young
and this is what a 26 year old should be
doing like popping your [__] at Beyonce
with your new man yeah but they've been
now together for a while so I think it's
also her being pretty settled and
content in her relationship enough to be
like you know what let's take this thing
for a spin
yeah I mean all the K's were at
Beyonce like Kris Jenner was blackout
like I lived for it did you see that
Beyonce had asked everyone to wear
silver in the audience and like pretty
much everyone did that's pretty cool
yeah yeah are you also familiar with the
mute challenge yes
I wasn't sure since it's like all over
my Tick Tock I didn't know if it made it
to real estate I didn't make it to Reels
I didn't know that we were adding
challenge to the second half of it
oh I think we are I think it's just like
Beyonce said mute so you shut up look
around everybody oh mute I will never
scroll past one of those videos like I
find it so interesting and she could
really and only two times I think has it
been like complete without some [__]
being like Beyonce
in L.A last night the the show last
night they did it like really well and
then the the show that everyone like
talked about forever was like night two
in Atlanta or whatever it was like you
could hear a pin drop it's actually like
the sickest thing and I think it's
really smart it's like a good way to
because every time people go to the
concert like of course you film at a
concert but everyone is filming the mute
moment so just a good way to keep your
tour in the news you know it's actually
very smart yeah I think that's also like
with this dress code thing I wonder what
it's for maybe it's for
um
uh recording of the concert
or I don't know Beyonce's just like a
very visual person yeah maybe she wanted
to see something beautiful and she's
like hose get dressed like we're going
out it's my birthday yes don't look
don't look like a slob speaking of
concert tour is not a story but Taylor
and uh not admitted PP brain announced
that she is her tour is a movie October
13th three days after campaign counselor
you'll be able to watch at AMC Theaters
she's yeah she's not doing like a
streamer you know she's kind of going
back in time Reviving the movie industry
and I read somewhere so the production
cost she of course paid for it herself
was between 10 and 20 million dollars
and they far surpassed that in pre-sale
tickets for the AMC Theaters I think it
was at like 26 million which is that of
like a Marvel movie that's like what
Marvel movies make in pre-sale wow yeah
so like she and she did all of this
without because uh obviously there's a
strike but also I don't think she needs
a movie studio to produce it for her she
has her own production company but in
the midst of the strike which is still
ongoing after maternity leave but you
said like after Labor Day things might
clear up now we're on strike alert yeah
but this is a sag sanctioned project
because it's not sag got it so she's not
working with the studio it's strike
compliant yeah she got approved you know
got it well I'm kind of struggling
because as someone who hasn't seen the
era store yet and I do plan to see it
next year when she comes to Miami I
don't really want to see it you shut up
the movie before I see the tour so I
don't think I'm going to no you
shouldn't I did get tickets for Friday
night the night it comes out I also got
for Saturday at noon everyone was buying
Friday night and then like it was
loading so slow I'm like let me just
check Saturday completely empty I got
like the best seats in the house so I
have some shitty seats Friday night that
honestly I just might give to someone
and I'll wait the 12 hours
you're nuts yeah no I agree just sleep
in
take a melatonin it's a 10 p.m showing
like I'm not in the mood take a
melatonin at 10 rise around 11. head to
the movies yes stay off your phone yeah
I think that's what I'm gonna do but
like what's gonna be that you didn't
already see no nothing I just want to be
a part of something is that okay no no
I'm not asking why are you seeing it I'm
asking what why do I have to see it
Friday night yeah like what are people
gonna post on Tick Tock in those 12
hours that you didn't already see
nothing I just like want to support my
girl you know and be be up be be the
first one like I'm annoying like that
okay cool I'm just gonna give her
attention is that what you wanted me to
say okay I'm doing it for attention no I
honestly didn't think that I thought
that maybe we could break down some of
these preconceived notions that you have
in making more comfortable with the idea
of just going Saturday at noon
but I literally said like I am going
Saturday at noon no I know I said I'll
probably give up my seats Friday I agree
with you you were feeling like it was a
consolation and I'm just like I don't
think I said that I don't remember
recall saying the word consolation no
because you wanted Friday night
no I don't recall
I just feel like this whole Situation's
kind of been like thrown in my face when
I was just being honest and vulnerable
you're such a victim you're so strong I
am searching for victimhood the very
awesome story you're so brave yeah I
know like I'm literally amazing and
courageous and vulnerable all at the
same time yeah thank you so we'll see
what I end up doing with my tickets
she'll be there Friday night
[Laughter]
literally so I don't think I'm gonna see
it just to bring it back to you I think
that's the right call and you can by the
way like you'll get the DVD it'll be on
demand like actually I also read it's
gonna be on a streamer in 13 weeks she's
allowed to so after 13 weeks of it being
in theaters like uh whatsoever
exclusively with AMC Theaters she is
then allowed to take it to Market again
to see if you know there's any bids I
guess the bid's the first time weren't
big enough
damn
and her power knows no bounds like
wherever she puts it people will go so
it's like why should I give all my power
and my influence to a Disney like I want
100 million dollars and I'm sure they
weren't willing to give that in these
dark Economic Times thanks Joe Biden and
now
we're all having to go to the theater so
I'm okay with it
yeah well again you're very brave
I know
I'm getting political are you ready for
a fifth and final story
oh no I'm not oh
crazy that was close
close call Fifth and final story that's
brought to you by liquid IV per chance
yes
proper functional and major essentially
major and liquid liquid IV is the number
one powered hydration brand in America
their hydration multiplier is the one
product you're missing in your daily
routine use it first thing in the
morning before a workout or just when
you feel run down
a personal favorite of mine is after a
long night out a hangover a long flight
that's a perfect place for a liquid IV I
always have a liquid IV in my purse let
me tell you how it saved Ben's life this
weekend I just happened to have like it
was like actually sitting in my purse
for months I didn't even know it was in
there and after the wedding we were at
Ben was not okay and it saved his life
lemon lime flavor that's my favorite
um so here's how it works one stick of
the liquid IV you put it into 16 ounces
of water mix it up it'll hydrate you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone it contains five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C with
three times the electrolytes of leading
sports drinks it's made with quality
ingredients it's non-GMO and it's free
from gluten dairy and soy liquid IV
believes that Equitable access to clean
and abundant water is the foundation of
a healthier World they partner with
leading organizations to fund and Foster
innovative solutions that help
communities protect both their water and
their Futures to date liquid Ivy has
donated over 39 million servings in over
50 countries around the world I can't
stress how important it is just to have
liquid IV in your house like buy it keep
it in your house when you need it you
need it and you just want to make sure
you're fully stocked they have so many
good flavors strawberries so good I
really like lemon lime I have been
filling up my Stanley with my new ice
machine water and a liquid ID because
you've got to stay hydrated while you're
breastfeeding and also just like
postpartum you're just losing a lot of
fluids and I've been wanting to I keep
saying like multiply by hydration it's
hydration multiplier liquid ID and I
just got a fresh shipment of amazing
flavors pina colada I like the
strawberry lemon lime so good
breastfeeding mamas there you go there's
to see real people real flavor real
hydrating grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code toast at checkout that's 20 off
anything when you shop at better
hydration today using promo code toast
at liquid iv.com you're welcome for that
one girl I was like you're literally
welcome what can you say except
you're welcome our fifth and final story
um really is brought to you by liquid IV
because burning man took place oh my God
this weekend and it was kind of crazy a
nightmare flooded cause driving ban and
just total chaos at Burning Man the
driving ban at Burning Man was lifted on
Monday allowing the estimated 64 000
people remaining at the festival to
escape the ground and that were
transformed into a muddy Quagmire by
torrential downpours so they're calling
it Exodus operations that were
officially underway in BlackRock desert
in Nevada thanks to drier ground
Festival organizers said in an update so
the festival grounds were completely
flooded I didn't know obviously burning
man takes place in the desert but I
think like this piece of land at one
point like many many years ago was a
lake and it like dried out so the sand
is like different so it raining like it
literally became like quicksand people's
cars were like literally being swallowed
by the Earth so you're saying it's not
like other sand that's exactly what I
was trying to say thank you got it so I
saw like photos I think we also like
pictures and videos of just like this
muddy mess people were told to like
shelter in place they couldn't leave
right and when we think of shelter in
place like we're at our homes the whole
point of burning man is like it's this
non-capitalist non-conformist Society
where like money isn't real so it's like
people in campers with limited food
limited toilets limited water very
limited resources so it's it's kind of
it's a nightmare yeah it's a nightmare
but also one of the like foundational
I think some people were like this is
where you know it's very about like
self-reliance and and community so I
think some people were like leaning in
leaning in um other people were like get
me the [__] out of here yeah so if you
started to drive away in your car like
your car would literally like end up
half stuck in the mud like up to your
neck I saw like Diplo and Chris Rock
walked for six miles until they found
someone with a truck who gave them a
ride just looks like a complete and
total nightmare and the the um toilets
were out of commission
no way and it's actually really sad two
people died yes but it's unclear if they
died not due to like the weather some
like for other causes but then the
weather stopped emergency vehicles from
being able to get to them you know what
I mean yeah but yeah it's it's sad and
crazy and scary and I feel like people
love to [__] on burning man because it's
like a little silly it's easy to [__] on
um yeah but this was just a really crazy
plot twist um no and when whenever I
feel like there's like a major like
disaster or catastrophe I think like a
very natural human response is to be
like oh my God like that could have been
me like whenever something happens like
whether it's like an earthquake or
whatever you always think like that I
could have been in that place or
and honestly knowing that I would this
would never happen to me I would never
be a Burning Man
I didn't think you would be confused
with someone who would be yeah like I I
was never gonna go and it's this changes
nothing like I was never gonna be there
yeah I'm the opposite of Burning Man
even though katuin five years being like
Jackie we have to go to Burning Man
literally no I would literally never
like where where I draw the line is like
no running water no Wi-fi no money like
you can't like buy stuff it's like trade
yeah like I'm sorry I love like this
world you know you don't want to escape
just for a few days
no if I do like I'll take a trip but you
know who goes to Burning Man Who Elon
you know who does go to burning man
who's kind of like a darling of Burning
Man
for me it's like so incongruous like
she's so fabulous I feel like and she's
also like a capitalist Queen no she's
like also a materialistic Material Girls
houses like to me that makes no sense
now I know she has like that whole DJ
side of her but like to me I get
confused by that yeah
I don't know I feel like some people
like just come in and out for the
afternoon
you know yeah I don't really see her in
a camper but what do I know but I just I
don't see it do you think like you
should promote the camper and the
counselor at Burning Man in a camper 100
the camper and the counselor greater
than the camper at Burning Man
I don't think that was ever Up For
Debate no I think some people would say
like no Burning Man over this chill
those people know nothing I did end up
on like a burning man side of tick tock
and it was it was nice to see people you
know in times of stress people being
like I'm located at this lot or whatever
we're cooking food if you need food come
like it was it was nice it was nice you
know Human Nature yeah no I and I think
those are the the principles of the
festival so people are practicing what
they preach but in times of like dire
catastrophe like it could be lord of the
things every man for himself right and
you always say like
you like to think if I got stranded on
an island with like 10 people I know
like we'd never turn on each other but
you never know well it was also
I think in the beginning everyone is
like we're in this together and it
lasted about three four days
it you know I think it's over every time
we watched a final of sadness oh my God
don't even don't even bring that filth
to our show it was a terrible movie it
was literal filth Phil like Duty
everywhere but I feel like you know if
if this if these conditions had lasted
longer that's when people start to turn
the beginning is true always like
Kumbaya let's you know make a fire we're
United it's worth mentioning most people
who go to burning men are on drugs oh
yeah
so that adds like a more of like it's
it's more um
what's the word I'm looking for
like when you're like you're able to
deal with something
I'm just like not gonna be able to give
you the word you're looking for what is
this word okay hold on it's like
oh my God it's something a ball like not
dealable but like like
oh God
it's like palatable kind of but like
I don't even remember what I was trying
to say move on this is a job for
thesaurus.com yeah it's more like I'm
gonna try tolerable yes
tolerable like something you know a
situation like this when you're on drugs
yes but I also think it could make
things like more perilous panicked Panic
yeah for you for sure for sure like I
can't even smoke pot I'm like always
like on edge yeah and ever since bonue I
just really I don't participate anymore
I understand
thank you so those were the first five
stories I feel as though you needed to
know them if you're in the car on the
way back from burning man I hope you're
okay I'm glad you got out you know maybe
next year don't do it like I just feel
like not worth it there aren't really
any toasters at Burning Man toaster's ex
burning man is not a community like that
exists like if it's a Venn diagram it's
just two circles next to each other yeah
but like you know toasters X Stagecoach
huge middle it's three circles it's one
one Circle yeah
I agree so I don't know if we have any
toasters actually if you were at Burning
Man and you made it out and you're
listening to this episode and perhaps on
your drive home uh sound off in the
comments how was it you okay but only
when your car is fully stopped in park
of course of course of course and unless
someone else is driving right right
passenger yeah yeah oh my God speaking
of driving like yikes I have to learn
how to drive again I know I was thinking
about that while you were here you had
just learned and and they was doing
really good I was challenging myself to
drive every day then I left I have to
listen don't worry about it like no I'm
not figured out I'm not like it's a
problem for another day but it's
certainly a problem it no it's not a
problem it's just disheartening
no it's even though they really say it's
like riding a bike like you don't forget
but you just really were not I wasn't
experienced yeah like I was still
learning so that doesn't Tesla
self-drive
first of all you have to work up to
self-driving you have to prove yourself
as a good enough driver to prefer them
to give you self-driving and also I'm
not really interested in self-driving
um it's freaky it's a little freaky any
like Tesla accidents like they are
they're uh
are the self-driving ones like I just I
don't know how much I would trust it but
I mean it can't be worse than me
you know
it's true the bar is low now that I
think about it what are you gonna have
for lunch it is lunch time right yeah
that's a really great question one that
I hadn't thought of previously I think
I'll have Trudy's warm bowl ugh enjoy
I I don't know do I make something Zach
maybe a bagel with eggs yesterday that
was good I think I'm gonna have brunch
and then lunch love you know I'm still
in a breakfast state of mind I'm in a
breakfast
still mind and all right oh maybe a wrap
I don't know by the way at a glance
first episode back how does it feel it
feels good actually I think this was a
great episode we covered so much ground
I know I thought we were really gonna
have to go on for three hours but now
we're 20 seems to have done it I knew we
could do it and also I am like my clock
is
yeah no surely like gave you an hour 20
like let's not be ungrateful yeah like
now we can do the post show upload
things I can get them on the boob we're
good
guys it has been an absolute honor and
it brings me great joy to say this thank
you so much for listening to The Chosen
Millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and we're
podcasting events on Spotify iTunes
digital public radio I already castbox
all the places
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing truly awesome day just don't
forget to soak up each other's
awesomeness you know drink awesome
Shooters love ya bye love you bye